en ukraine c'est le cimetière des héros
à chaque sépulture son drapeau
dans cet océan bleu et jaune une jeune
veuve sur une tombe et derrière elle un
défilé d'obsèques le mari de yulia
soldat est mort d'un éclat d'obus en
plein coeur il ya trois mois
il était tout pour moi et j'étais tout
pour lui
la guerre ce sont des morts mais jamais
je n'aurais pensé qu'elle prendrait mon
mari
maxime et yulia voronkov va elle a 20
ans quand elle le rencontre à l'hôpital
elle est infirmière il est son patient
marié il espérait un enfant pour l'année
prochaine
l'histoire de maxime ou celle d'une
génération d'hommes fauché par la guerre
alcock l'ukraine mérite ce sacrifice
mais quelle dureté
je crois en notre victoire le pays doit
garder espoir mais quant à moi mon
avenir c'est une autre histoire
l'ukraine affirme perdre entre 100 et
200 combattants par jour des hommes
entre 20 et 50 ans ici as l'audience que
dans le donbass il suffit de lire les
dates de naissance sur les tombes pour
le confirmer
j'étais à côté
[Musique]
ce matin c'est un jeune homme de 26 ans
orphelin de père et mère que ses
camarades soldats mais d' tentèrent
je ne compte plus que j'ai enterré des
dizaines peut-être 100
autour du cercueil de sergueï volkov
certains soldats en uniforme ont tout
juste 20 ans
on a du chagrin de la peine et de la
haine pour les nuits
et c'est dur moralement
des batailles ont décimé des milliers de
blessés c'est l'aumônier militaire qui
voit cette génération meurtri
ce sont des hommes intelligents briand
qui s'en vont ce qui pouvait rendre
notre société meilleure nous perdons le
coeur de la nation
jusqu'où pourra aller l'ukraine dans ce
sacrifice
au grand cimetière des héros une image
frappante ces tombes fraîchement
creusées pour les prochaines obsèques
comme un alignement qui semble ne pas
finir